secondly there are that percent or five
percent or whatever it is that small
proportion of questions where they don't
define it for you and then you do have
to make a choice but they'll give you
enough information so you can a
ambiguously work it out right so what
you need to do is look for a result that
you're asked to prove look for a result
that you're asked to prove so again I
went and found an example for you this
is fairly short so I'll just read it up
okay and by the way I would love you to
follow along with me because we're gonna
work this out together and there's an
important thing that I haven't shown you
before I'm just gonna use this as my
example a submarine of mass M s is iam
you've ever seen it before it's
travelling underwater at maximum power
okay so here's my um here's my submarine
okay I'm just gonna assume rather than
up down like the power that's a that's a
forward backward okay so it's going
forward ready I'm gonna call that
forward direction I'm gonna call that
positive so I'm trying to construct with
you when you have more than one force at
play right and in resistance that's
often the case this is how I'm going to
diagrammatically represent it's very
helpful at maximum power its engines
deliver a force F on the submarine okay
so that means it's going in this
direction that's the direction it's
traveling in that's the direction of
motion but as well as motion which you
can see there's a force in the positive
direction that you can't see and they
call that capital F that's the engines
then it says the water exerts a
resistive force so it's going in that
direction a bigger direction like so
proportional to the square of the
submarine speed V okay so this is this
is now the situation where we have to
choose and they don't give you an
equation right so we have to choose is
it gonna be kV or M cable you can see I
put it over here to represent it's it's
opposing the motion this is my axis
right you must always define which way
you think is positive negative okay and
if it's on the diagram that's enough but
I I now have to decide okay but then
part one says this I'll explain why so
I'm required to prove right DV r DT
equals 1 over M F minus K squared okay
so they don't give me a minute to find
stuff for but they do show me a result I
have to get you right and based on this
only one of these can be the case
so they've imagined they have to find
this for themselves and then this is the
result that they've gone ok so which one
do you begin with well you just you just
try one you just try one okay eventually
you'll start to realize that you can you
can make educated guesses as to this but
he's the way I'm going to be here is my
crush my own son I'm gonna say the
resultant force right I'm not going to
call a capital F because capital F has
already been provided in the question is
something else I think what's the
results in force well it's the it's the
sum of these two forces right I've got a
positive force and I've got a negative
force okay so I'm gonna add them up so
I'm just gonna just for the sake of it
I'm gonna try our way it was the square
wasn't sorry squared squared okay
I'm just gonna try having mass in the
picture okay so I'm gonna go F okay
that's the positive one
I might even plus that's the engine okay
and in the opposite direction I've got
em kV square is that okay so I'm just
testing this out right now what happens
I'm trying to get to this DV on DT DV on
the teeth we know that better by its
normal name which is acceleration right
so I could say weight resultant force
that should be mass times acceleration
DV on DT right I know this about
resultant force so then I've got this oh
yeah
and like oh this is by the way there's
only worth one mark that's why it's not
very much more to this do you like oh I
just have to divide by M seek on TV on
DT over here one over m f - MK squared
what oh right so I tested this out but I
didn't get to the result they were after
right so clearly in their envisioning
the question right this is not where
they began because that's why I have an
extra factor of M over here okay
so you tried it didn't give you the
result they were asking you to prove so
this is wrong our assumption was wrong
so all you need to do is this
okay we weren't in that mask then and
then we get the result okay so that's a
little bit weird but it's actually very
similar so they're defining it for you
right it's just that you have to put a
couple extra steps in to get there
all right so it's a bit awkward but
finally thirdly you need to compare
resistance versus retardation remember
we have introduced these terms before
okay they're about force sorry yeah
they're about force or they're about
acceleration right which ones which
which one's about force resistance about
boss
whereas retardation is about
acceleration so think about this and you
can read some of the examples in your
textbook right suppose they tell you
right that retardation is proportional
to say just velocity don't worry about
squaring stuff alone so if retardation
is reporting that's an acceleration
thing right so that means the
acceleration is proportional to the
velocity
yes it's retardation so it's opposing so
when I introduce an equation right
it's opposing and it's proportional they
go okay so now if I want to think about
the force then little forces MA isn't it
so force would be this times mass so I
get this result if they tell me that
retardation is proportional to velocity
on the other hand if they tell me
resistance is proportional right or
resistance is not a bad acceleration
it's about force so if that force is
proportional to velocity right well that
means mass times acceleration
yes is equal to minus K V
so you can see the difference between
these two lines as to whether your
resistance or retardation do you have
mass in there or not so I mean I don't
even need to say okay there I can just
say this okay
so this is another way look at the
language of the question which one are
they giving you to decide which way you
go okay